hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
actually had plans to make a video in
regards to this but I guess that video
kind of got soiled as we now have
information on what's happening with May
and what this whole spiel of new content
or old content coming back to the game
for the month of May due to the delay
that's happening with the newest season
so let's talk about that as always like
the V if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new I cover the informational
side of foreign or the being the balance
changes the he rotates the patents and
the leaks if when we kept this today
with everything happened in the world of
foreigner I never miss out on an update
though if we stay subscribe the channel
and with that let's get started with
today's video so on the blog post on
their website it's as whereas while we
work on our next season coming June 11th
2020 we promised you that we would bring
back some activities for you to enjoy in
the meantime and here they are each week
of May we will bring you one special
game-mode and the rewards from each one
of the last year's events unlockable
through all the game modes and if we go
to the road map that is 100% true pretty
much every single week is going to have
something crazy going on for the game
starting off at April 30th which is just
a couple days away we're going to have
the throwback game mode hyper zoo with
rewards from the black priors or pahst
as well as the warrior challenge the
content of the week which I presume is
going to be stuff from the black Pryor's
riposte and then the arcade quest that I
believe went with that actual game mode
on May 7th we're gonna have a throwback
to Dance of Death with the rewards from
these shadows of the heat so kiri event
followed by once again content probably
related to the shadows the heat so carry
event and then in arcade quest on the
14th is going to be the throwback
game-mode carousel of Ragnarok with
rewards from the wrath of real man
Gunther event an execution or challenge
more content of the week regarding
probably towards that event and then in
arcade quest and then as you expected on
the 21st we will have a throwback game
mode of carousel fire the rewards from
Jean whose gambit which of course was
the soon event more content of the week
in regards to the soon des gambit and
then the Orman gundar's March as the
arcade quest and
twenty-eighth we're just gonna have an
archaic whaa so a nice chill relaxing
day and then on the 29th of May
it'll be an XP fest going for the
weekend an a-rank to vanquish or
challenge so all of this is cool and I'm
super excited but I have to clarify one
thing
this might sound interesting for a
couple reasons whereas oh my god you
know the black prior events coming back
and I can get this stuff for soon dah
that's not exactly the case they say on
a website that it is the rewards are
only for the specific available heroes
and of course that means the heroes that
were available throughout that time
during the event so during the black
prior event you could get every single
piece of equipment you know anything for
any of the main characters of the game
but in terms of the year three hero
seeing as black prior at the time was
the only hero available during the BP
event you can only get that stuff for BP
if you play heat so kiri you'll have to
wait till the 7th to get the stuff for
her and then the 14th and the 21st you
can't get stuff at during the black
prior event so soon dot is only going to
be able to actually get gear during his
own event on the 21st so pretty much
exactly how the formula was during in
the actual year 3xf now all the
characters are out so quick run-through
on the 30th of April you can only get
stuff with black prior if you play a
year 3 hero on the 7th with the heat so
carry event you can get the stuff for BP
and heat so carry on the 14th is BP heat
so Carey and your man Gunther and on the
21st
it is the BP heats up here your man
Gunther and soon de are the characters
able to get rewards of course the other
year one heroes the marching fire cast
and the original cast are all going to
be able to get this stuff as they had
released prior to these events actually
coming to the game all this information
is on their website with specific
timings on when this stuff starts and
ends so I'll leave a link down to the
website and the blog post that they put
out if you want to see specifics on all
of that if I didn't clarify enough and
then to end off the blog post they stay
all words are gonna be unlockable
through all game modes except for the
character symbols that are exclusive to
arcade just like any normal type of
event except this is a little bit of a
twist as these are old events coming to
the game for a week but there's a lot of
them coming
you know I'm actually kind of upset I
was really really excited today it's you
know it's noon I just woke up I was
super excited to get started on this
video I was gonna release tomorrow about
all these new ideas that I had of like
oh year you know season five might be
coming back or and they kind of got
soiled by the roadmap I'm not yeah
that's not a bad thing of course I like
I'm glad that we got a confirmation of
what's coming I just kind of wanted to
make the video and brainstorm with you
guys for a bit but regardless I like
actual confirmed information rather than
speculation so this will have to do
there's one thing that they didn't
mention in the roadmap and there's
probably a pretty good reason for that
and I was actually going to bring this
up in that video I was going to make
tomorrow or go up live tomorrow and it's
about May 4th you know may the 4th be
with you Star Wars all that stuff going
on if you played the game last year you
know that there was lightsaber effects
in the game where everybody's weapons
had some sort of lightsaber coloring to
it and it was [ __ ] amazing it was one
of the best things we had even though it
was only for a day it was super fun to
play around with and hopefully they
bring that back are they gonna do it
again that'd be sick honestly I'd be
totally down for literally just
rehashing what we did last year but if
they somehow build off of that that's
perfect and I think they could totally
pull this off as I do believe that the
only characters that had released from
last year till now we're I believe
you're mag under and soon da cuz I think
the gameplay used in that video was he
Toki REE
so all they really have to do is just
make that same kind of style with the
neck with those two characters and then
figure the stuff out with the old
characters as maybe they have the old
design files or however that stuff works
in game design now that is of course if
they actually had the plans to do this
sort of thing hopefully that comes out
I'd be super excited to experience you
know the may the fourth thing again
especially for the newer players they
haven't gotten a chance to do as this
was such a fun thing to do but yeah what
that guys like to view if you do enjoy
subscribe for new I covered the
informational site or fauna that being
the balance changes the here updates the
patch suits and leaks if any we kept
visited with everything happening then
the world of foreigner and never a sound
or not that we stay subscribe the
channel I don't know if I'm gonna have a
video on Thursday in regards to the
roadmap I might do a weekly video like
this just covering once again
what
those awards are for the week as you
know maybe some of the newer players
don't understand or maybe you're an
older player but want to remember every
single thing that's coming to the game
so let me know the comments below if I
should do that
as the week's go by during this month uh
like I said let me know if I should do
that but like to be if you do enjoy guys
like I said take care of the girls today
peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]